[Music]
that
hey guys and welcome back to the fallout
4 show today I'm gonna be leading you
through the top 5 mods in this humble
fallout players opinion for Fallout New
Vegas I figured this was a good time to
check out some of the greatest mods from
the previous game before fallout 4 comes
out and we get a little bit silly with
the mods to come
now our first mod starts as soon as you
spawn it's called the role players
alternative start if like me you're a
little bit bored of creepy old doc
Mitchell staring at you as you wake up
you can spawn in a creepy Shack instead
but the good thing about the Shack is
that you've got everything you need to
create your own character no longer are
you forced to be the boring old courier
you can be whoever you want to be so you
start off choosing your attitude towards
the world it's basically the size in
your starting karma if if you want to
really roleplay and think I'm gonna play
as an utter [__] this game feel free
the tag system is still the same but the
good thing about the tag system now is
your tag skills will determine how you
start the game so I've chosen energy
weapons there that means that I've got a
higher chance of starting with an energy
weapon which is suitable because when I
go down to my weapon preferences I can
choose pistols smg's rifles shotguns
default so your playstyle can determine
how your characters made if you love
playing with shotguns start with a
shotgun that's your that's all you the
history part is my favorite though this
is going to decide where you spawn what
you support with the attitude of people
towards you when you spawn so I'm
choosing Brotherhood of Steel because I
want to start as a brotherhood of steel
knight every young boy's dream you don't
want to star in Goodsprings you bolt in
the alternative start
so because I'm Brotherhood of Steel I'm
going to spawn near the Brotherhood of
Steel bunkers you don't spawn in the
bunkers because that's a hole that's
gonna mess up quests but this is
literally me as I clicked the spawn
button as I walked out of that Shack
I just emerged as a noble Brotherhood of
Steel Knight complete with the laser
weapon because I chose energy weapons so
all the decisions you make will dictate
how you spawn
so if you've got a character that you've
always wanted to play as in the world of
fallout chances are you can create it
for this mod if you want to play as an
enclave remnant SPECT in explosives this
is you I've got a giant grenade machine
gun because I chose high wealth so the
wealth actually decides how good your
equipment is as well if you've got loads
of money in the bank it makes sense the
you're gonna carry around like the best
weapons that you can buy this is just a
lowly NCR soldier
I chose guns and I set my weapon
proficiencies with shotguns so I got a
nifty shotgun and I spawned at the NCR
outpost so you can completely decide I'm
just gonna play as an NCR ranger just to
NCR ranger quests I'm gonna be the the
everyman of the NCR and do completely
what you want to do each faction has
choices within that faction as well so
here I'm starting out as a Legionnaire
because I chose caesar's legion now you
don't have to be a Legionnaire you can
start as a legion slave or a victim if
you want to kind of rise up against your
legion captors you can be connected to a
faction without actually being part of
that faction this is basically just a
career if you start if you want to start
as a Korean be no kinda boring I guess
you'll start with shotgun Mojave Express
makes sense of the courier to start
there because we're going anti doc
mitchell there's even an option to spawn
as the village idiot which for some
reason just gives you scraps of clothing
and a rolling pin yeah now this is our
second mod project Nevada now project
Nevada brings an incredible amount of
new features to the game its objective
was to make a mod to make Fallout New
Vegas a more interesting more
challenging and a more fun experience
for people now these are all gameplay
elements that they've added that don't
feel alien to new Vegas it feels that
you're playing new vegas version 2.0
they don't want it to feel like you're
playing a mod they want everything to
feel natural and like it belongs in the
world of Fallout so we've got all these
new features like sprinting an immersive
HUD cybernetics so this is us with a
brotherhood of steel helmet on now if
you've ever wore a helmet most
tell me or anything like that you can't
just see clearly you get this like
obscure vision it's like you're looking
through a visor and this is really cool
because it adds another level of emotion
to the game you're carrying around the
same piece of technology on your head
that the rest of the Brotherhood do but
I mean at one point it's gonna become
nighttime and things become a little bit
harder to see now with it being an
advanced piece of tech wouldn't it be
nice if you could see in the dark well
this has you covered it's got a little
bit night vision in there who doesn't
want that when when the Brotherhood
steel are doing their patrols at night
they don't want to have to you know
carry a flashlight so it's wretched the
dark see you get some night vision and
even better than that is thermal vision
so now you can roleplay as some kind of
special ops nighttime stealth
Brotherhood of Steel infantry soldier
tax to kill great khans in the dark
because all our reasons
but this this is amazing like no idea
how project divider created this but all
I did was hit a key on my keyboard it
didn't like my game and it brings this
entirely new visual effect to the game
and feels completely different as well
now the thing with the visors if you
wear glasses you'll know what it's like
to scratch your lenses bit of a pain but
this is a bit worse so if you take too
many bullets to the head chances are
it's gonna crack your visor nobody wants
that so this kinda gives you a new
reason to keep your equipment in peak
perfect condition this is the brand new
one clear as day that's what you want
you want the the nice clean visor but if
you do get it broken that's how it looks
I've put this in here because sprinting
is actually going to become a new
gameplay feature in Fallout 4 as
sprinting is tied to your action points
as it is in this mod although I have
been cheating so they're not going down
but this kind of it brings again a new
element of gameplay something so simple
like sprinting can add so much and it
kind of makes sense that if you sprint
into a dude and bodycheck them to the
ground they're gonna go flying and you
sprinting tactically I guess knock adieu
to the floor and then give them a
triple-barreled shotgun to the face and
if you want to draw a sword on a
caesar's legion decide that you're brave
enough to body check and Legionnaire to
the ground and then hack him up open
feel free you are a braver man than I
but all the equipment i've used in this
little clip like that sword the triple
powered shotgun
that's all in project Avada as well
again have created armors and weapons
that feel like they belong in the world
of Fallout and that feel like that part
of the the new game but add again some
new elements to Fallout New Vegas these
armors modeled by the lovely Raoul
so after we added in a bunch of new
gameplay features with project Nevada I
figured it'd be nice to have you know a
few more guns and considering Kate and I
played through the original fallouts a
few episodes ago I figured what what
better choice
then to grab all those classic for our
weapons and bring them into new Vegas so
classic for our weapons brings in 63
weapons with original models and sounds
from Fallout 1 fallout 2 and Fallout
Tactics you can see they're quite
effective I mean this one's a bit of a
bullet hose I'm not sure if it can
really fire that fast but it's great to
see that people can bring their favorite
weapons from classic Fallout games and
see them in like 3d glory and in New
Vegas so I mean if this pulsating
Gatling laser was your thing back in
fallout 2 well look at you you've got it
again and because the old fallouts kind
of took some artistic liberties if you
will and our weapons are a little bit a
little bit out there you can you can
bring that kind of craziness back into
Fallout New Vegas with these rather
over-the-top laser guns but the fact
that they're all modeled super well are
their effects are done super well all
the sound effects sound great again it's
something that feels natural to New
Vegas as it should really because
they're literally the the weapons that
have been in previous horror games just
rebuilt in 3d given a little bit of love
and brought into Fallout New Vegas and
it's not all rocket launches and laser
beams you got to be simplistic sometimes
the old classic fallout weapon the super
sledge looks a little bit different it's
got like a pulsating tip which is very
bizarre but it seems to be quite
effective against Brotherhood of Steel
just a few swings and you're there I
think maybe the pulsating tips used to
break em it's because yeah that's the
only explanation I have there's no other
reason why they should break but the
fact that someone sat down and kind of
brought these classic weapons into the
new engine
new game it's May I hope we see plenty
more of this like reimagining and
rethinking the old weapons and things
that were being played with in the
original games and getting to revisit
them in the newer titles and all the
models are super impressive I get well
these are a gatling gorse weapon who
doesn't want that
you go from Gatling gorse to a wrench
I mean tied with project Nevada sprint
and tackle they've kept it balanced some
of them are quite over-the-top like this
the giant alien weapons and the big
rocket launchers but some of them are
also basic things that you would start
fallout with like like a shotgun you go
from giant stylish machine gun to just
your basic sawed-off shotgun so if
you're not getting enough service at the
bar or if there's a if there's a queue
for you to get your drink it's one easy
way to clear out and if you're really
thirsty then I suppose we can we can let
you off although this kind of attitude
just to get a drink is probably
unhealthy at least it gives you a nice a
nice relaxing quiet bar to hang out in
and think about all the evil things
you've done mod for this is our quest
mod I'm gonna I'm gonna shut up now so
you can hear the brilliant voice acting
and operator I assume you're here for
the position correct hell yes it's open
I can begin the interview if you're
ready I only have one question are you
willing to kill people for money yes No
a question that I'm constantly being
asked so this is New Vegas bounties at
New Vegas bounties one in fact this is
actually a three part series now its
storyline continues all the way from one
to three the mod creators some guys
actually done about six or seven mods
now I believe and they are all just
amazing the amount of love that goes
into the voice acting and the scripting
is incredible so you start off just you
know hunting targets like rogue Rangers
fiends Raiders drugs
taking their fingers don't know why
bringing them back to mr. Steven Randall
and he gives you some money so it starts
out very basic you know you just killing
people for cash that's that's nothing
new that happens in games all the time
but what I really love is that they've
created quite a detailed story and list
ignore him
quite a detailed story a list of quests
you to go through so it starts out very
basic you're just killing people for a
few caps eventually there's puzzles to
solve you can get kidnapped you can
choose whatever way you want to kill
people
there's decisions to make and you can
decide how to handle situations and
there's some it's a movie references as
well which is just a little bit charming
so this is Tony Idaho ten points for if
you get this reference all you need to
do is give him a quick 1/2 with a
sawed-off take his finger head back to
Steven but it's corny right Vegas
bounties it caused self an action mod by
think that underselling how good the
story is if if you sat me down in front
of new Vegas with this mod installed and
you didn't tell me this was this was a
mod I would completely believe you if
you told me Bethesda made this the
quality is of all the the quest mods
they include voice acting and add new
content to the game this is way up there
even even if people are asking about my
yarbles if you've always wanted to kill
the people from Clockwork Orange
I suppose this is this is your
opportunity
and they've made great use of like
in-game assets to give a new flavor to
some of the characters so I mean what
creepier dudes are there than people
from the white glove society cannibals
and people who want to punch my yarbles
so here this was a quest where I had to
find lost children
Frederick mr. Krueger was waiting for me
in the Hills so it really gets
interesting that puts so much thought
into these quests when I first started
it was like okay well I'm just I'm a
hired gun I'll assassinate people earn a
little bit of money but I ended up
getting invested in um Stephen Randall's
storylines he's got a lot of cool
information about him like why he wears
the bandanna
all of this kind of thing kept is super
interesting you're not just
assassinating random people in the Hills
like you didn't start you get to blow up
creepy ghoul children as well
I dunno doing a waste under real service
and Fredrik rumor isn't allowed to live
Freddy Freddy Krueger's hand isn't in
the game but the deathclaw born that
works just as well I think there are
many enemies that can like quite kind of
frustrate you and some of them are
really dangerous
prepare to be ambushed outnumbered you
really kind of step on some toes when
you're a bounty hunter so be prepared
for the unexpected if you play this mod
and like I said you can choose how to
kill your target as long as their
fingers intact so I got bored of
shooting people and decided a grenade in
the pocket would work probably just as
well if not a little bit better still
got a finger so you know Dave's still
gone get paid and modern number five
this is this is our beautification mod
it's called advanced shaders EMB so I've
done is I've taken a shot with the EMB
on as you just saw and this is a shot
with EMB off this is how New Vegas
normally looks so here we see the lights
of New Vegas with our EMB looks blue
- for the neon lights great this is
default New Vegas graphics still looks
good but it kinda looks like someone
just put a gross gray filter over it so
you can see the sunset over a Hoover Dam
look looks great in be off still looks
good but the EMB adds a little bit extra
to it it includes ambient occlusion
indirect lighting depth of field Sun
shadows now this shot is great because
you can see the blue is the sky the
orange is the fire and then you turn the
E and B off any like ah now I'm just a
little bit disappointed bring back the
EMB and not only does it help the
landscape actually improves the textures
and the lighting and the effects on
characters and MPC is as well I mean my
characters ugly there's no fixing that
but at least that um be helped but we've
got a little bonus mode as well this is
a baby deathclaw commander i could not
could not include this mod this is a
beautiful mod you find I'm getting
broody now you find a baby deathclaw egg
and instead of you know doing what most
people would do and crushing it because
death was awful keep in your back pocket
long enough for it to hatch and there he
is
your little new loyal deathclaw friend
what I really love about this mod is
that you spend a lot of the time in
fallout fearing these little beasts well
I say little beasts when you usually
fight them they're about eight foot tall
and kill you in one hit whereas this one
is up to your ankles and I don't think
it could bite its way out of a wet paper
bag yet but you get it as a little tiny
hatchling and I suppose you're taking
its role as as mother so I gave gave
them a name Kevin bat sword I think I
think people in the comments are
appreciate you suggested that for a few
of our characters I think I think Kevin
is a good name for a baby deathclaw so
to keep it big and strong you need to
feed kevin meat it takes 50 meat for
Kevin to go from a little baby all the
way up to a huge dangerous terrifying
bloodthirsty adult they can't stay cute
forever I'm afraid so this is Kevin
after about 25 meals
see he's grown horns he's a quote
unquote adolescent now so the deathball
get hungry once an hour so I decided you
know what I'm tired of letting time take
its take its necessary role
let's speed things up a bit so I fed him
fifty times and you can see just from
the start of this fast-forward clip
starts off still quite small like half
your height and now this is Kevin fall
adult isn't he beautiful he's his own
strong independent death tour now so you
don't actually have to feed him anymore
he's just gonna be a loyal companion
he'll find food in his own basically
that means he'll eat anything you killed
together but this is as big as he grows
he's not as big as a you know a standard
deathclaw but it's okay we love him all
the same but once you get them fully
grown he can find and eat a couple more
things to give him new effects but I
figured since the baby deaf world
couldn't really stay alive in a fight
against a gecko I wanted to see how he
would do against the group of thugs now
he's a big boy and it looks like he just
wants to give them all a hug but I don't
think they appreciate the hugs like that
this is gonna go in for a high five the
thug doesn't want a high five Kevin I
mean I appreciate your enthusiasm as
overeager as Kevin is for the for the
cuddles I think you should stop but he
is a loyal companion and a beautiful
little baby deathcore but that is the
five well I suppose six with the bonus
mods that I would choose if if you made
me choose the top five those the ones
that I would pick hands-down
you've got alternative start it kind of
brings a fresh spin on the story and
allows you to make your own project
divider which adds a lot of new gameplay
features the classic fallout weapons
which kind of make you nostalgia for the
original fallouts
the enhanced shaders EMB which makes it
all beautiful again new Vegas bounties
which adds a ton of new gameplay
and then baby deathclaw because who
doesn't want a baby deathblow but those
are my top five if you guys have a top
five list of mods that you would like to
share with me
and I would love to check out any mod
suggestions that you have and I am
looking forward to getting ready to mod
the unter hell
fallout 4 so make sure you leave me your
mod suggestions in the comments guys
thank you so much for joining me and
watching this episode of the fallout 4
show I've been Dave and stay safe out
there wasteland
[Music]
with the bow don't sweat now
you got a beautiful tone you gonna burn
my throat
I'm going